okay we've got the junior team of the
year 2011 Blackpool school national
finalists upper darby from a while back
mystery spinner Chrissy apsley what was
your favorite moment from the tournament
oh well firstly going out to Java County
Creek I was really good experience but
when i took my opening working when it's
in the first ever game is really good
excellent roda Ashley calls it fast
bowler good batsman very dynamic at for
your moment um I don't think I really
I'd like a magical moment but like the
whole experience was pretty amazing
because the venue was like fantastic and
all of it yeah you enjoyed go to Pizza
Hut yeah we saw what you have yeah
actually speaking of which one half as
much as Holly quit football random
player hard hitter yes holly was your
best man um just playing at Derbyshire
and yeah playing huntin option and
finally to captain what was your name
again well Christopher's oh yeah um I
think the best moment was just stepping
out onto Darby Darby's cricket ground it
was just a brilliant experience yeah
excellent and of course Darby was the
end of a really long road wasn't it how
many games did you win on the way y abs
ash bad Twain know all of them no no not
one in the final 13 matches what's next
ok so this quick cricket tournament who
can tell me where it started no right
yeah Rick I'm coming back yes okay and
then where did you go but big Bobby
so if someone else wanted to follow in
your wake okay it's a long trail isn't
it okay what advice would you have to
the next team who are going to go to the
final yes just right and just keep
praying and have fun hopefully you
gather yeah you'll make a good coach one
day just like Trey best and keep at it
and enjoy it may sleep because that's
why it's fun yeah I have fun and it's
not all about winning and take home yeah
keep your head high and just trying you
know get your goals okay and are you
proud of your achievements yes from team
is just to cancel we're very proud of ye
okay thanks